we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a very good question
and i'm going to be honest with you
about the answer okay listen to the
question then i'll give you my answer
hi david this is david from ohio
i was just wondering if trump was still
president
would more people be taking the vaccine
would everyone be taking the vaccine
would we be better off as a country
i was just wondering your thoughts on
that thanks
listen
yes
it is undeniable
that if donald trump were president
right now
more americans would be vaccinated there
is no question because the people who
follow science
who are vaccinated today
would still be vaccinated if trump were
president
but there would be millions of trumpists
who have not gotten the vaccine because
it has been joe biden overseeing its
rollout
who would have gotten vaccinated if
trump were president now the second
question is tougher would we be better
off as a country
that's harder to say because trump was
such an unmitigated unmitigated disaster
i i think long term we're better off
with joe biden rather than trump
even though you would have more trump is
vaccinated if trump were president but
i fully admit
the people that care about rhetoric
rather than science
they would likely be vaccinated at a
much higher rate if trump were president
today if you disagree with me let me
know but i don't think i think i i would
be lying to you if i denied that we have
a great bonus show for you today
september 18th saturday
might be trump riot's number two we will
talk about the measures security
measures that police are taking in dc in
advance of that
corporations tried to blame individuals
for the plastic crisis oh you got to
recycle that bottle
now states are starting to turn the
tables on corporations and sales force
is offering to relocate texas-based
employees
on the basis of the texas abortion law
very interesting what salesforce is
doing we will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com